hello and welcome to this video playing
drain you grandmaster hanson sooner back
Hansen from Denmark let's go um I don't
know what he plays actually we've played
a number of games but I don't quite
remember what exactly it was so this
double of you and Keller was something
where you get to learn what is set up is
maybe some c5 you have some sin t five
base sir ah the quadruple fianchetto
okay this is a very solid way of a
player for black to play Oh esox just
doesn't take
interesting the night is six something
like that I think I've seen this this
idea I never studied that mmm yeah why
not so he's going 45 or something along
these lines mmm not sure if we need to
or something hanging pawns hmm this is
this isn't somewhat rare a rare thing to
happen in those lines here that black
has feline cat out um and then goes for
any porn sir not quite common I wonder
how to arrange my pieces here too to
begin with this weekend's d3 quite a bit
hmm how does that work I wonder if night
before is something but I can probably
just move the Queen
yeah normally I would sit the take and
play night night if for immediately or I
come on don't really oh ok I don't
anticipate any book I was thinking you
would just go with the pawn
AOS feel silly I've used two minutes
there and they haven't anticipated a
single move by my opponent I mean might
as well just play whatever if you never
place what I expect but yeah it's okay
and it's not like this is a terrible set
up or anything he's got very active
pieces I like the structure this is
quite clear I like my structure its
leverage for yes so what to do here I
was thinking about Bishop aa3 if this is
an idea okay I can also do that i'm not
really believing in g5 that or something
drastic like that would you see though
for sacrifices here in one word yes he's
tries to sacrifice stuff okay but not
not anymore now the e-file is closed and
i tried to go for position where his
bishops don't and then when they don't
do all that much so do i want to take
now i think i have to learn let's see
the night should go to c4 or f1 okay a
voice it is great hmm i don't know to be
5 b 5 a 3 or something okay let's play
let's play its aesthetic for information
now was he play that queen bee to hear
no
then you go play in between there's
nothing particularly wrong with that I
can go to a 4 just attack the pawn took
me a really long time to realize that
and we should f1c for that something
that I saw before so timewise I'm
catching up a little bit ok
Jim really feel reasonably solid tee I
know it looks passive but he's got a
really bad porn structure and his
bishops don't do all that much I
honestly believe I'm better here I mean
maybe I'm totally not understanding the
position it's certainly possible but I
think I'm in good shape here famous last
words probably a bit
so yeah probably it's it's equal right
what can i play for a win here time our
ship d5 is probably simple yep let's try
but maybe I can do something you with
the pawn structure but promised a draw
it allows me to keep the keep the Queen
on okay surprising
anyway I no creen f6 but my time is kind
of lactating some of the decision here
check game ah yeah I have no time
catechin can can maybe okay this is a
draw I think I maybe had some chances
there so let's fire up fired analysis
yeah I was participating any move in the
opening really not um okay so yeah I
mean be takes a step terrible no it
isn't right I was thinking it would take
with with this that was my Indian n but
I I really didn't like this position all
that much Black is very active yeah but
ok he what he did is fine it's not like
I played badly I just I just never
anticipated to move age 5 h form yeah no
I'm going for this for destruction yeah
the engine degrees that white should be
bad of it maybe at one point I played 22
simple-minded OKC for isn't this wasn't
on my radio on hope you should be form
so what is this this this
I cannot move a single piece yeah so
probably this is why the engine wants to
do this and get this going 56 and into
equal yeah maybe he's got the bear of
Bishops but this is such a static
position it doesn't really matter so cut
this rope t1 yeah oops oops being safe
yeah I was thinking maybe I have some
chances here with the structure it
probably probably not yeah Queen takes
is probably a draw night h5 yeah it's
probably a job what can you do it was
never there was never a situation where
one of us was them M was clearly better
or anything like that it's just felt
like relatively correct draw ok guys
thanks for watching